نادية ، هل يمكنك أن تصف ما حدث
لك أنا من الأقلية العزيزية في
سنجار في كردستان وعشت في إحدى
قرى نزع السلاح والتسريح وإعادة الإدماج هذه عندما احتلت داعش
الأراضي في العراق سمعنا عن
الجرائم التي ارتكبت ضد المسيحيين
والأقليات الأخرى ولكن في وقت مبكر من صباح يوم
3 أغسطس.  2014 هاجمونا ما يقرب من
6500 امرأة وطفل من الإيزيديين
تم اختطافهم وقتل حوالي 5000 شخص
من المجتمع خلال
ذلك اليوم لمدة ثمانية أشهر
وفصلونا عن أمهاتنا وأخواتها وإخوتها
وقُتل بعضهم واختفى آخرون.  حتى الآن
تم اصطحابي مع مجموعات من الفتيات غير المتزوجات
وأخذننا جميعًا لاغتصابنا ، لم يأتوا فقط لمهاجمة أشخاص معينين ولكنهم جاؤوا من أجل الاستخدام.
اعتبرت أن ذلك
جائز بموجب الشريعة الإسلامية